are you excited for destiny too well now
we know exactly when it arrives what
platforms it's coming to and more this
was all revealed in the game's first
trailer which surprisingly didn't
feature a Led Zeppelin song anyway I'm
Matt and this gamespot news update is
going to run you through everything we
know about bungees next game destiny
tues first trailer shows returning
characters savala and Cade 6 talking
about the loss of Earth's last city and
injecting some humor and inspiration
into their speeches it's a little
disappointing because after the initial
teaser trailer I was expecting to see a
little bit of gameplay but we won't see
any of that until a live stream on May
18 however there is some good news
destiny 2 is confirmed to come to PC in
addition to ps4 and xbox one you'll even
get to try it out before launch thanks
to an open beta that you can get early
access to by pre-ordering we'll keep you
updated on when that beta is supposed to
happen so make sure to LIKE and
subscribe to be the first to know about
all of the destiny 2 news destiny two
launches September 8 and surprise it'll
be sold alongside a season pass it
includes two expansions that offer new
story missions co-op activities and more
and there will also be limited and
collector's editions that include the
season pass and various physical and
digital bonuses you can check out all of
the contents on gamespot com but if you
just want to see sci-fi headshots
courtesy of some explosive firearms then
check out our video on the five guns we
love from Mass Effect Andromeda
you